in this video today we shall list down
the top 10 most powerful transformers
from the michael bay
live action movies the transformers in
this franchise are very different from
the ones in the cartoons and other media
in the way that they are designed their
origin stories their powers
and their size as well there are also
many transformers like
metroplex primus and dragotron which are
extremely powerful
but were not seen in the movies so in
this list we will only include the ones
from the michael bay flicks
and list them according to their powers
and determine by our own
estimates which ones are the most
powerful
so now let's get down with this sickness
number 10 infernas infericus was a very
powerful semi-robotic demon combiner
that is formed from the inferno cones
which are
smaller robots and bloodthirsty warriors
of quintessa
he works as one of her chief lieutenants
and one of her most powerful fighters as
well
he is a very big robot around 42 feet in
height and very fast and agile
which comes to play when talking about
power in the transformers world
because size isn't everything as we can
see devastator being killed by the small
hip-hop robots
although he was incredibly ferocious he
was easily forcibly transformed back
into his constituent transformers
by optimus prime and then each of them
being killed by a single swipe of the
sword
number nine grimlock and the dynabots
grimlock is an ancient and powerful
warrior who takes the form of a
tyrannosaurus rex from earth
he is the leader of the mighty dinobots
of course these dinobots are very
powerful in their own
and they deserve separate spots on this
ranking but that won't
allow for other awesome characters to be
included as well
although he could easily destroy the
newly created decepticons and even chase
of megatron and the others
in the last knight movie he was still
defeated by optimus prime in a short
duel
in age of extinction number eight
sentinel prime
sentinel prime was a double agent and a
traitorous ottawa commander
he was optimus prime's mentor he was a
strong
and determined leader who held a firm
belief in his race position in the
universe
and expected respect from everyone
around him which he won by showing
himself as a ferocious and formidable
warrior
he was indeed one of the only fighters
to be able to defeat optimus prime in a
one-on-one fight
but to be fair optimus was not really
willing to kill his own mentor
until later in the fight when he was
forced to do so due to the unwillingness
of sentinel to change
number 7 the driller and shockwave i
know that i said that science isn't the
determining factor in power estimates in
a transformers universe
but to be fair a 1000 feet long brutal
subterranean
robot animal of cybertron does come out
on top of robots that are 20 to 40 feet
tall on average
like shock wave himself the driller was
shock waves pet
and was a very dangerous opponent having
a long worm-like body and several
appendages that worked
semi-independently they are the largest
creatures that live under cybertron's
surface
it was seen destroying skyscrapers with
ease and when both these two worked
together
which means driller and shockwave even
optimus prime feared confronting them
both at the same time
number six lockdown lockdown was the
main antagonist of the movie age of
extinction and
he was a bounty hunter that was employed
by the transformer goddess called
quintessa
locked down was a cybertron in bounty
hunter aligned with neither autobots nor
decepticons
who was hired to capture prime and hunt
down the remaining transformers on earth
using his very high intellect and
extremely potent battle tactics he was
able to capture
optimus prime and even the dinobots
storing them as trophies of war
in his ship the transformer was indeed
one of the most powerful but lacked the
ambition of power
he was killed by optimus in a very
lengthy duel
number five the fallen he was the first
decepticon and appears to be the most
powerful of them all as of the second
movie
his major purpose was to eliminate all
life on earth by destroying the sun
and to do this he turned against his
brothers the other primes who were
unable to beat him even
with their combined strength he
threatened the entire planet upon his
return and during his appearance in the
pyramids
he easily destroyed armies of military
tanks and aircraft of humans
he is indeed one of the most powerful
transformers ever as a prime
as none could defeat him but another
prime which is why he earns the number 5
spot
and optimus prime was only able to do so
after combining with jet fire
and also for the fact that megatron's
the fallen was very old and
was kind of weakened after years of
inactivity
number 4 optimus prime he is the leader
of the autobots and one of the most
powerful transformers ever
although he hides his power in most of
his fights and only shows it in true
fits of rage like when he battle
megatron starscream and grinder all at
once besting them all at once
but only being killed after he was
distracted looking for some with wiki
optimus has defeated infernicus has
defeated megatron
sentinel prime grimlock lockdown driller
the fallen
and all the others in the entries below
him so he deserves this spot
he was however unable to best three
others that will be shown
next number three dragonstorm
dragonstorm is a beastly three-headed
dragon the mighty gestalt form of the
legendary twelfth knights of econ who
oppose quintessa
at times dragon storm is only formed
from dragonicus and storm rain
it is logically unclear why the knights
could still transform into the same
dragon
after nemesis prime murdered one or two
of them but maybe the dragon could be a
little bit smaller after such deductions
and since the knights were able to stop
nemesis prime which is in fact
optimus prime and even nearly executing
him it is understandably logical to
conclude that
all of them combine in one as
dragonstorm would make it clearly more
powerful than optimus prime
number 2 quintessa on the number 2 spot
we have quintessa who was the one
who created optimus prime and possessed
a staff with immense power capable of
transforming
worlds when confronted by optimus she
easily subdued him and transformed him
into nemesis prime
an evil version of optimus she was most
likely
the one who sent lockdown to hunt down
and capture him
she manipulates other transformers into
doing her dirty work subduing them
into her will even megatron feared her
as he did her bidding
she is indeed one of the most powerful
in this universe
and number one of course unicron the
dark god of the transformers unicron is
the ultimate transformer as
he was dormant as a planet for billions
of years
as planet earth itself formed around him
over billions of years
following the events of transformers
last night quintessa attempts at killing
unicron have caused him to slowly awaken
from his slumber
his horns rising from the planet's core
no matter the universe whether it be the
live-action movies or cartoons
unicron is always the biggest baddie the
biggest threat to all transformers and
hence
the most powerful rivaling the god
primers which didn't appear in bay
formers so
unicron holds this number one spot other
notable mentions of powerful
transformers are megatron of course
the de facto leader of the decepticons
and the rival of optimus
devastator with his immense size and the
mysterious berserker
and now we come to the end of the video
so put your thoughts down in the
comments section below
and disagree all you like and do hit
that like button for support
check out our other videos as well since
you might have missed a few as
youtube isn't promoting our videos as
much recently anyway subscribe to be a
part of the minecube family
and ring that bell button for updates on
new videos
right here on minecube till the next one
take care farm
you